how does your smartphone know exactly
where you are
the answer lies 12,000 miles over your
head in an orbiting satellite that keeps
time to the beat of an atomic clock
powered by quantum mechanics poof let's
break that down first of all why is it
so important to know what time it is on
a satellite when location is what we're
concerned about the first thing your
phone needs to determine is how far it
is from a satellite each satellite
constantly broadcasts radio signals that
travel from space to your phone at the
speed of light your phone records the
signal arrival time and uses it to
calculate the distance to the satellite
using the simple formula distance equals
C times time where C is the speed of
light and time is how long the signal
traveled but there's a problem
light is incredibly fast if we were only
able to calculate time to the nearest
second every location on earth and far
beyond would seem to be the same
distance from the satellite so in order
to calculate that distance to within a
few dozen feet we need the best clock
ever invented enter atomic clocks some
of which are so precise that they would
not gain or lose a second even if they
ran for the next 300 million years
atomic clocks work because of quantum
physics all clocks must have a constant
frequency in other words a clock must
carry out some repetitive action to mark
off equivalent increments of time just
as a grandfather clock relies on the
constant swinging back and forth of a
pendulum under gravity the tick-tock of
an atomic clock is maintained by the
transition between two energy levels of
an atom this is where quantum physics
comes into play
quantum mechanics says that atoms carry
energy but they can't take on just any
arbitrary amount instead atomic energy
is constrained to a precise set of
levels we call these quanta as a simple
analogy think about driving a car onto a
freeway as you increase your speed you
would normally continuously go from say
20 miles per hour up to 70 miles per
hour now if you had a quantum atomic car
you wouldn't accelerate in a linear
fashion instead you would
instantaneously jump or transition from
one speed to the next for an atom when a
transition occurs from one energy level
to another quantum mechanics says that
the energy difference is equal to a
characteristic frequency multiplied by a
constant where the change in energy is
equal to a number called Planck's
constant times the frequency that
characteristic frequency is what we need
to make our clock GPS satellites rely on
cesium and rubidium atoms as frequency
standards in the case of cesium 133 the
characteristic clock frequency is
9,192,631,770 hertz that's nine billion
cycles per second that's a really fast
clock no matter how skilled a clock
maker will be every pendulum wind-up
mechanism and quartz crystal resonates
at a slightly different frequency
however every cesium 133 atom
universe oscillates at the same exact
frequency so thanks to the atomic clock
we get a time reading accurate to within
one billionth of a second and a very
precise measurement of the distance from
that satellite let's ignore the fact
that you're almost definitely on earth
we now know that you're at a fixed
distance from the satellite in other
words you're somewhere on the surface of
a sphere centered around the satellite
measure your distance from a second
satellite and you get another
overlapping spoon
keep doing that and with just four
measurements and a little correction
using Einstein's theory of relativity
you can pinpoint your location to
exactly one point in space
so that's all it takes a multi-billion
dollar network of satellites oscillating
cesium atoms quantum mechanics
relativity a smartphone and you no
problem